Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Japanese science-fiction thriller film
called “AI Amok.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Kosuke Kiryu is a brilliant scientist from Japan
who has developed an advanced AI called Hope for
medical purposes. His main motive for all the
hard work he has put into the AI is his wife’s
cancer treatment. If the technology is approved by
the government to be used in the medical sector,
it will not only save his wife’s life but will
be a revolutionary step in human development.
At the beginning of the movie, Kiryu is in
his lab working when his brother-in-law,
Satoru Nishimura comes to him with some paperwork.
It turns out that the government has refused to
endorse the use of AI because of the absence of
relevant jurisdiction. In the following scene,
Kiryu, his wife, and Satoru are on a beach with
Kiryu’s daughter Kokoro. His wife is in the last
stage of cancer and needs immediate help from
the AI. Although Kiryu invented the AI, he and
his wife refuse to use it illegally without proper
authorization. The family takes a picture together
at the beach. A few days later, Kiryu’s wife is
on her deathbed, she passes away after saying that
she hopes the AI will one day bring joy to many
people’s lives. If it had been approved in time,
Kiryu could have saved his wife. A year after her
death, the medical AI system is approved by the
government and distributed among the people.
Not long after, it starts being used in every
sector like law, finance, entertainment, and most
importantly medical. Because of the technology,
cures for several diseases are found. In only
a few years, Kiryu's achievement is belatedly
celebrated worldwide. His brother-in-law Satoru
becomes the president of Hope managing it overall.
After fulfilling his wife’s dying wish, Kiryu
doesn’t want to live in Japan anymore. So, he and
his daughter move to Singapore. The popularity of
Hope rises exponentially when a personalized watch
that takes care of one’s health is introduced.
Now, people do not have to go to the doctor
to be diagnosed with problems like brain tumors
and cancer. Although most of the world celebrates
the new invention, there are some who believe
that it will cause the problem of unemployment
to rise exponentially. Many people protest
against Hope but it has become indispensable
to the lives of most Japanese citizens.
In 2030, Kiryu and Kokoro are living in a
beach house in Singapore. However, Kokoro misses
her mother a lot and desires to return to Japan.
One day, they get a message from Satoru saying
that the president of Japan wants to award Kiryu
for his achievements. Taking the opportunity,
the father and daughter fly back to Japan
and are surprised to see several protesters
outside the Hope headquarters. They are welcomed
by Satoru and the entire company with a round of
applause. Following that, they are given a tour
of the building. They get to see the server room
where the “heart” of hope is kept. It is a massive
machine that serves as the core motherboard of
Hope. The place is highly secured because the
machine is connected to the lives of every Hope
user. Two drones from the “heart” recognize Kokoro
using their face scanning feature. Following the
tour, a press conference is held to welcome Kiryu
and for him to talk about his invention. During
the conference, the protesters manage to break in
and interrupt Kiryu while he is talking.
Following that, Kiryu meets a police officer
named Sakuraba. Sakuraba has been bothering Satoru
to let the police department use Hope to hack
people’s personal belongings and solve crimes.
Since it would be a breach of people’s privacy he
has been denied the request. On his way out, Kiryu
is followed by a journalist who is clearly against
AI. He hands Kiryu his card claiming that he wants
to interview him. When Kiryu and Kokoro are in the
car, the little girl notices that she has lost
the only picture of her mother. She runs inside
with the staff to look for it while Kiryu and a
girl drive to the convention where he is being
awarded by the president. Kokoro and the others go
to the server room to look for the lost picture.
Meanwhile, in several different hospitals in
Japan, Hope suddenly starts to malfunction. Many
patients die because of the lag while the medical
workers panic, not knowing what is causing it.
Somewhere else, the president is preparing
for the program but she suddenly drops to
the ground. It turns out that her heart pacer also
ran on Hope which stopped working. She is rushed
to the hospital but to no avail. The automated
driving system that uses Hope also malfunctions,
causing several accidents. As Hope stops working
throughout the nation, Satoru and the engineers
in the headquarters are informed. They run to the
control room to find out what is wrong with the
program, leaving Kokoro alone in the server
room. Because of the breach in the system,
the security lock is activated and Kokoro is
locked alone. The news makes it to the TV and
Kiryu also finds out about the malfunctions. When
he calls his brother, he is even more worried to
see Kokoro locked alone in the server room. With
time, the room’s temperature will drop below zero
for the machines to cool. They will have to bring
her out before she dies of cold. The programmers
at Hope get to work and find out that there has
been a strange log-in to the protected server
which supposedly caused the malfunctions.
They locate the area where the hacker is
and send little insect-like filming devices
to the location. Meanwhile, a worried Kiryu
is stuck in traffic. He opens his bag and finds
a tablet that is uploading the virus to Hope.
Just then, the police locate him and arrest him
for being the hacker. It is clear that someone is
trying to frame him but Kiryu has no way to prove
it. Just then, a car accident takes place nearby
that distracts the police and he manages to
escape. Throughout all this, the journalist
from earlier is taking his pictures from a car
behind him. With the suspect escaping, Sakuraba
and his team are given the responsibility to catch
him. Taking the opportunity, Sakuraba uses the
Hope AI program to look for Kiryu, without waiting
for permission. Two officers named Godo and Asano
are also added to the team to help them. Godo
doesn’t feel comfortable seeing Sakuraba invading
the public's privacy to look for Kiryu. Using
CCTV cameras, cameras from people’s dashboards,
and even cameras from people's mobile phones,
Sakuraba is able to locate Kiryu. At one point
Kiryu realizes that he is being watched, so he
enters the sewers. He calls Satoshi from there and
tells him that someone is trying to frame him.
The call is being traced so Sakuraba and the team
can hear them talking. Kiryu reveals that when he
first created Hope, he made sure to program that
it worked for human comfort and satisfaction.
He believes that in recent years someone has
programmed Hope differently, that is why it has
started to work on its own and not take human’s
command. The AI will soon evaluate citizens and
terminate those it deems worthless. This puts the
whole nation at risk of being killed by it. Just
then, we see an infant in a stroller that is run
by the AI. It calculates the overall medical
bill that the infant might have to pay in its
entire life and deems it to be unworthy of life.
Following that, the stroller falls off the stairs
eliminating the baby itself. To stop the mass
murder, a new program must be input to the server.
After the call ends, the soldiers enter the
tunnel and find Kiryu. He breaks his tablet
so he won’t be tracked. Sakuraba loses all
stats about his location after that and Kiryu,
yet again, manages to escape. Goda and Asano get
out of Sakuraba’s control room. After hearing
Kiryu talk to Satoshi, Goda believes that he is
innocent. The two think from Kiryu’s perspective
and come to a conclusion that he will probably
go to Hope’s second data center in Sendai.
Back in the headquarters everyone tries to
get Kokoro out of the server room but is
unsuccessful. She lies in front of the heart, cold
and scared. To reach the data center in Sendai,
Kiryu boards a ferry hiding inside a truck. Goda
and Asano also get on the same ferry. Kiryu had
stolen a tablet from a person which he uses to
program. The police track the signals and find
out his location. The officials at the ferry are
informed and told to check everywhere for him.
When they eventually find him, he makes a run
for it and ends up on the top of the deck.
Goda and Asano tell him they are there to help
but before he can reply a sniper from a helicopter
fires at him. To save his life, Kiryu jumps
into the water and disappears. A while later,
he opens his eyes and finds himself on a boat in a
harbor at Sengai. A local fisherman had saved him
from drowning. He says that he is thankful for
Hope because it saved his wife’s life and lets
Kiryu go. Meanwhile, many protests against Hope
are being held throughout the country. Kiryu has
been declared a terrorist by the media.
In Sendai, Kiryu goes to an abandoned
university that was the place where he first
invented Hope. He is soon joined by Satoshi.
It turns out that when they talked on the
phone the last time, he used a code word
to call him there. Goda also debunks the code word
and drives to the university with his partner.
Kiryu and Satoshi start writing a program to stop
the destruction being caused by Hope. The computer
scans every citizen of Japan who uses AI and plans
to terminate them according to their past. It
will take exactly six hours for the mass murder to
start. The engineers at the Hope headquarters also
find this out and start calling their families
to ask them to stay away from their AI devices.
Kiryu then figures out that no one had hacked
the program and the virus was manually planted
in the heart. On checking the heart’s data
for the past few months they find suspicious
activity. But on checking the CCTV footage, Kiryu
is shocked. It turns out that Satoshi was the one
who uploaded the virus. However, Satoshi denies
the claims saying that he was just doing a regular
check and doesn’t know what went wrong.
Just then, the soldiers arrive at the hideout
and fire at Kiryu. To save him, Satoshi jumps in
front and gets shot instead. With his last breath,
he begs his brother-in-law to save the people.
Kiryu manages to escape yet again while being
followed by the police. Goda and Asano also
follow them behind in their car. Amidst the chase,
Kiryu’s car falls off the road and crashes several
feet below. The police check for him in the
wreckage but do not find his body. Police officer
Sakuraba uses AI and the CCTVs to look for Kiryu
and finds him but when the police reach the
location, the person turns out to be someone else.
It is then revealed that Kiryu has bugged the
police’s AI system, making it malfunction.
While they try to look for him, Kiryu manages
to return to the Hope headquarters and meets
the chief engineer who is willing to help him
stop the massacre that is about to happen.
However, Sakuraba and his team somehow make
it to the headquarters and surround him.
Kiryu tells the soldiers that the
real culprit is actually Sakuraba.
Then, he plays a video of Satoshi inputting the
virus to the heart. It turns out that he was
actually tricked by Sakuraba who was standing
outside the server room when it happened.
Even though it is proved that Sakuraba caused
Hope to malfunction, the soldiers still follow
his orders. Sakuraba then says that Japan needs a
powerful system to rule the world. With something
like AI, he could have all the power in the
world. As he confesses to all his crimes, a flying
insect-like device records their conversation
and broadcasts it live to the entire world. Now,
everyone knows the truth. Goda arrests Sakuraba
and takes him away while Kiryu runs to repair
Hope and save his daughter. He programs the code
and makes the heart scan it with Kokoro’s help.
Hope finally remembers its past and the reason for
its creation. The door to the server room opens
and the father and daughter reunite.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.